so now here comes an example question
right if for example i said to you
well let's try an exponential function
with a base of
2 so maybe you want to jot this down
with me
if i considered 2 to the power of x
if i wanted to find the derivative of
this what would i do
now in much the same way as you saw
if i can dress up something weird as
something familiar then i can work with
it right can you see we know how to
differentiate when it's e to the power
of something
this is not
e to the power of something but if i can
make it look like that
then i can differentiate it right so
what i want to do
is i want to try and
um this is my question right
how do i write
2 like that's the base that's there
but i want to write it in terms of e if
there was an e there i'd be okay
like even weird things with e i can deal
with them but i've got a 2 there so i
want to write 2
in terms
of
e that's the question okay
now
i gave you these three
kind of to like nudge you into thinking
about how to rewrite questions
this is the last piece of the puzzle
here and you're like why is that why is
that there right
so
do you see to get from here to here
you used logs right and then your
calculator could handle it from there
whichever way you went okay
we're gonna do much the same thing here
um
if an exponential is like a a lock then
a log is like the key and vice versa
okay so what i want to try and do is say
well how do i connect these two numbers
with a log right so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to say
log base something
and i'm going to give that a name i'm
going to call that like some number okay
all right now i want to connect these
two together
which one of these do you think would be
a nicer base to choose
think about what your calculator can do
is is two a base that your calculator
can handle
not without like filling around right
but it can handle it if it's e so i'm
going to put e
as the base and then
two
up here
okay
now you know how you went from an
exponential here to a log equation
we're going to do the same thing but in
reverse so have a think for a moment i'm
going to let you actually i'm going to
give you like 15 seconds to jot this
down and then think about what would
this look like if i
rearrange things i want
an exponential looking equation
running a log equation can you take a
second to do you think you have an idea
of how it would be written or you're not
sure
what if you like similar to that yeah
it's very very similar right so do you
remember how i said like oh the base
here becomes the base here
so the base here is
yeah very good so i'm going to write
uh e
very good so then these just swap sides
here that's equal to two
okay
now even though you're like mr i haven't
i haven't done very much here like
what's what's the point why why did i do
this this is actually
the key you just wrote 2
in terms of e do you see that 2 is e to
the power of this number
except uh i need another color
k is just this apparently
do you see that
that's k
so therefore i can write this now this
bit's a little bit tricky right
i can say that 2
is equal to e
to the power of
all of that
now because this is like it's a long way
of writing i'm going to use a lazy way
of writing it which is with that n
the n stands for natural and it's the
same button you see in your calculator
right ln
now i'll admit this
looks really weird okay you're like mr
wu isn't two a much nicer way to write
this than all of this mess okay
i'm gonna say why we're doing this for
two reasons number one
the goal that i set out for right i've
written two in terms of e so this will
help me differentiate but there are
other ways to see this right for example
if i said to you
um
zero
point
nine
repeater
i don't know if you know about this
theme your name repeat is a weird number
okay uh it's you know 0.9
and they go on forever right
except there's actually a much more
common way of writing this number that's
more familiar okay um i don't know if
you know what a third is equal to do you
know what a third is as a decimal
0.3 appetito
right so in order to get
this like to get from 0.3 repeater to
0.9 repeater all you have to do is
multiply it by
3.
so if i multiply this by three
that means i also multiply this by three
is that okay
so on the right hand side i've got 0.9
repeater
what do i have on the left
should be weird right you're like how is
this
the same as this
it looks different but if you want to
think about it this way some people say
like this has to be smaller right this
has to be smaller than this because look
it starts with a zero right
but if you say like hey tell me what's
the difference between these if you said
0.000001 something like that
wherever that is it means this number
stops but it doesn't stop it goes on
forever so it's like these are the same
thing
these are the same thing this is just a
weird way of writing it but here's why
it's going to be useful
we want 2 to the x
so to get from 2 to 2 to the x
i'm going to raise both sides
to the same
power power of x is that okay
e to the log g
okay
do you know what to do with index laws
when you've got something with a power
and you raise it to another power what
happens to the indices
yeah you just multiply them yeah so it's
actually quite easy to handle it's just
going from e to the i guess like
log 2 times x now can you reach for your
calculator for me can you punch in log 2
for me
what does it give you
yep that's right
yeah fantastic so i'm going to put 0.7
right
so this maybe you want to drop down with
me this is roughly
e to the 0.7
x
and the reason why i highlight that is
because this log 2 looks weird but it's
just a number it's about 0.7 okay so
therefore
when i go to i've got 2 to the x on this
side right when i go to differentiate
that's what i'm trying to do here right
if i try and differentiate one side
to dx
all i'm doing is i'm differentiating
this side here which is e to the power
of about .7
x but i'm writing it in this way because
that's exact
um i should put this in brackets so you
don't mix those up okay
do you remember what happens when you
differentiate something like this we had
to use chain rule but i'm not sure if
it's still it's from last week do you
remember
fine let me give you an easier example
if i differentiated something like that
would you know what to do with it
i can refresh your memory okay so here
we treat it as kind of like there's an
inside part and then there's an outside
part so we differentiate each one one at
a time
so first we just look at this part up
here and we say what's the derivative of
three x
when you differentiate three x you just
get
it's ring bell yep you just get three
and then when you differentiate the rest
of it it's e to the power of something
which is just
e to the power of something right we
just we saw that earlier right so you
just get this
so at the moment i don't have three i've
got
like 0.7 or log 2. so when you
differentiate it
just like this 3 came out the front
this
log 2
is going to come
out the front is that ok
and then the rest of it stays the same e
to the log 2
x
[Applause]
okay now you've done a lot of work here
there's just one last step this is us
differentiating
2 to the power of x
but did you notice there was this um
this funny spot where i rewrote it in
this weird way this thing here
do you see that this
it appears right here again do you see
that
that is the same as that they're
identical so therefore this is just
2 to the power of x
times
log 2. so therefore i can sort of write
this in a much neater way and i can say
the derivative of
2 to the x
is
2 to the x
multiplied by
log of whatever that base happened to be
that's the result we're trying to prove
look this is an exponential function
with another base
and you just differentiate it and in
fact it didn't have to be two i chose
two because um
it's a nice number you could have chosen
three you could have chosen five um
anything would have worked so in fact i
can make this any number
if i call it like
i don't know uh
uh
a
for any number
it's a to the x
log
a
and what's nice about this is that we
already know that this works because if
you put in e this is the one we already
know about right so you can put a big
box around this if you like right
if we put in the number e
the derivative of e to the x is e to the
x
log
e
but that log right
that's log base e
so if it was log base e of e
that's just equal to
1 e to the power of 1
gives you e
so therefore it's like oh the derivative
of e to the x is e to the x times 1
which is we already knew that right it
just sort of confirms what we had before
okay